good morning welcome to Hillsdale
colleges kirby center my name is David
Bob I service director here it's my
pleasure this morning to welcome you all
to our first first principles on first
Friday's lecture of 2012 we're really
delighted today that were joined by one
of the leading political scientists in
not only this country but anywhere Jim
Cesar has taught at the University of
Virginia and has done so in a wide array
of subjects including the one on which
he'll be speaking today before he is
introduced formally I'd like to commend
to your attention one of his most recent
books it's a collection of essays about
the Constitution and constitutionalism
it's called designing a polity America's
Constitution in theory and practice it's
available in hard copy as well as an as
an e-book and you can find it online
it's really a great collection of
illuminating essays I'll have a few
announcements about upcoming events
January is a busy month for us here and
we'd like to invite you to be part of a
number of occasions that we'll be having
this this month and next but we'd like
to get to our topic this morning it's
the 2012 election America's moment of
truth to introduce our speaker this
morning a native of Miami Florida who is
experiencing winter for the first time
today is not so wintry here in
Washington DC we might have to send him
to our campus in Michigan or it's just a
little bit colder now ed Walton is
serving as an intern with the kirby
center op-ed
thank you dr. Bob James W Caesar is the
Harry F bird professor of politics at
the university of virginia where he has
taught since 1976 he's of the author of
several books including nature and
history and American political
development presidential selection
liberal democracy and political science
and the perfect ty the true story of the
two thousand presidential election
co-authored with andrew bush he has held
visiting professorships at the
university of florence the university of
basel oxford university and the
university of bordeaux he received his
PhD in government from harvard
university today he will be speaking on
the topic the 2012 election america's
moment of truth please join me in
welcoming dr. James Caesar well thanks
said for the very kind comments and
introduction I traveled up here this
morning on the train from
Charlottesville enjoying our good old
American high-speed train which ambles
gently along at about 40 miles an hour
in contrast to the more than 250 mile
250 kilometres a mile that one finds on
the french tgv of which our president
dreams fondly every night I'm sure
incidentally I'm reminded here that the
the West was one inch by inch not
centimeter by centimeter back to this
train which passes through some of the
loveliest scenery Virginia has to offer
allowing one when you take count of the
speed to cultivate what John Carranza
referred to as affections and long
memories that attached to ancient powers
of life in the provinces and it also
affords you some time to reflect say on
what to put into a lecture well
well one nice innovation on this train
organically grown has been the internet
and in consulting the hillsdale website
on the way up I observed that it placed
this talk right square in the middle of
pundit land I quote with the Iowa
caucuses held on january third and the
New Hampshire primary a week later this
presentation will outline what is at
stake now if the politics of the moment
is my charge then David must have
mistaken me for my colleague Larry
Sabato whom I see from time to time on
CNN or Fox for I raised the self-evident
elevating question what could possibly
be added to the cornucopia of political
analysis that flows daily from our
Airways newspapers and blogs I think
when historians look back on our day I'm
sure that they will what will strike the
most about our campaigns is really not
the vast sums of money spent on the
races but the extravagant application of
intellectual energy some of it by the
nation's finest minds to the analysis of
each and every aspect of this ongoing
event I wouldn't want to lament the
waste of intellectual resources devoted
to this object except you might ask what
these people will be doing if they
weren't talking about the campaign but
the attention given to the campaign is
at least extraordinary it already struck
Tocqueville in 1832 and he was referring
only to the final election campaign here
is a citation from Tocqueville and a
liberal igitur a gesture at any
Hillsdale presentation he said the
election is the daily theme of comment
in the newspapers and conversation the
subject of events thought and the
interest of the moment incidentally took
a worried about the national elections
especially those in which an incumbent
was run
as the effect and our quota was to
replace patriotism of the incumbent with
trickery listen to this passage which
I'll I'll read it is impossible to
observe the normal course of affairs in
the United States without noticing that
desire for reelection dominates the
president's thoughts and the whole
policy of his administration has been
towards that aim that his slightest
actions are subordinate to that aim and
that particularly at the moment as the
election draws near his private interest
takes the place of the general interest
in his mind did I say that this was
written by Tocqueville or Charles
Krauthammer well not to ignore
completely a charge that has been
assigned to me I now offer I think nine
minutes no more boilerplate political
analysis before turning to the subject
today which I already adumbrated in the
remarks about trains and that is what is
at stake in 2012 beyond the nomination
is a choice a choice even in the minds
of many Americans between America and
Europe many are thinking in these terms
and many of the candidates I'm speaking
of the Republicans frame the election as
an election in just this way America or
Europe well now for the ponder tree
which draws from a simple framework of
categories that andrew bush and i have
used in a series of election books that
dates back to nineteen ninety-two the
framework simply reminds us of the the
three general factors that voters weigh
in making their nomination choices how
they weigh these different factors
depends on each voter the timing in the
process and the of course the election
year but it's a rough way to begin
analysis the free factors are first the
issue position are more generally the
ideological slot of the candidates so
let's say something this year like
libertarian conservative less
conservative or maybe moderate conserved
in other words there's a slotting of
candidates that voters way and that
candidates themselves try to influence
we see this going on even now with Newt
Gingrich trying to slot all of his
friends the triumvirate of himself
Santorum and Perry against what he calls
a moderate candidate Mitt Romney second
is the person of quality of the
candidate his or her perceived
competence stature connectedness to
people like us and of course
electability third is what one can call
a mood or theme indicating for example
that people seem to have it in for
insiders or people in government or in
the federal government whether their
politicians are not themes like that
well let's begin by looking at this last
one the mood which has probably been the
least important in this campaign but
still not insignificant its youth could
be seen in and still can be seen in the
stump speeches of the candidate Rick
Perry stresses that he's not from
Washington Herman Cain made it a selling
point that he was a businessman and not
a politician and Mitt Romney two
mentions that he's a businessman is the
first element of his speech even if it
was only because he could not make it in
the NFL in a party that this year's
seeking to limit and constrained big
government there's some obviously
advantage in this posture not being a
Washington insider still it hasn't been
decisive a candidate from Washington can
claim that he or she was instrumental in
fighting big government there in
Washington and I think this worked
pretty well for Michele Bachmann it
worked for Newt so far as he was speaker
and leader of the revolution of 94
though he was obviously caught on the
defensive greatly for his enterprise
afterwards that fed off Washington
contracts which made him look more like
the Washington insider and this could be
an issue for Rick Santorum now the
current
conservative coming on whom the other
Rick as Rick Perry are already targeted
for being a major ear marker and
pork-barrel ur so santorum a at least
have some explaining to do on this theme
of mood next is the factor of the
personal attributes of the candidates to
date this has probably been the key our
most important factor in this nomination
race to this point the candidates have
fallen out of contention those who have
less for any rejection of their
ideological position or for mood then
for their perceived inadequacy as
credible candidates or persons for the
presidency I mean you can go through the
list beginning with Donald Trump so
proved himself a clown Michele Bachmann
who was impressive in some ways but
thought by many not to be quite up for
prime time Herman Cain who obviously
fell because of certain personal
problems Governor Perry for a lack of
skill and debate and made him look I
think many people turned on and for that
reason Newt Gingrich for a number of
things but I think also certain
questions about whether he's would be
the sort of person you'd want as
president Santorum is not yet gone
through this process and we'll see how
he comes out so I think this has been a
key element in this campaign which leads
one person Mitt Romney now when you look
at MIT romney's persona it's true that
he began is the only candidate Gingrich
aside whom everyone America and the
Republicans knew about before the others
had to make a name he didn't have to
make a name for himself people knew who
he was from the last last campaign so he
didn't face the problem of getting
himself known he's been called and was
called the front-runner curious though
if you actually look after august who
was leading the polls most of the time
nationally it really wasn't mitt romney
so curious kind of front runner if he
should be called the front-runner of
course now he is but most of the time he
was behind either Gingrich or cane or
Perry
I think as a candidate he shown himself
it's not perfect to be the one that has
emerged and thinking the consensus of
everyone as someone who's competent and
and presidential so while the others
have fallen for lack of it he's at least
maintained his credibility as kind of
viable presidential timber and may be
the only one to have done so so far
there's some other aspects of his
persona that are interesting but people
are reflected early on affected he's a
Mormon which may have heard him getting
some boats with some segments of
evangelical Christians but I really
think the real point is not once you
leave theology side is not the fact that
he's mormon but really that he's wasp
our typical wives seen him speak and
followed him around a little bit New
Hampshire he doesn't easily connect with
the average guy because he's not the
average guy in anyways come up in an
affluent background he said the best
education imaginable don't tell anyone
he speaks French so people can admire
and respect him but they don't easily
cozy up to him and couldn't have
problems in some places on that in that
regard although that being said if he's
ever the nominee I don't think this
would be a major problem for him the
sorts of people that he don't cause it
won't cozy up to well nevertheless I
think prefer his elite ism to Obama's
elitism that is a business elitism or
wasp elitism to an intellectual snobbery
he said to be the establishment
candidate now because of this whole bevy
of endorsements he's received including
from such preppies as Dan Quayle and
george bush senior maybe not the sort of
people that romney wants to see himself
hanging out with when you think about it
sometimes are some of this may have been
for the reason of where he stands
politically but I would say actually
he's been endorsed in spite of where he
stands politically at least that hasn't
been the major factor he's been endorsed
because of the judgments about his
persona person that he's the
only our most competent candidate in the
race and that the others don't measure
up you could easily imagine many of the
people who are endorsing orb endorsed
and will endorse Mitt Romney you could
easily imagine that endorsing someone
else if that someone else were in the
race in fact it would preferred a more
conservative candidate certainly a
candidate who wasn't attached to
Romneycare so this isn't these
endorsements aren't an establishment
circling around Romney to protect the
kind of moderate Republican ISM but a
recognition i would say mostly something
about estimates of his persona finally
when you look at this three-part right
tripartite analysis there's the slot or
ideology and this turns out it's in many
races there are often primaries going on
within primaries that is you have a slot
like this race the Conservatives and
it's a race among those and so there's
two races going on at once now in this
race if you want to try and indicate the
different slots it's clear that there's
a one division that all agree on and
that is libertarianism burst all the
rest that's a recognized slot and then
what is the rest well it's not perfectly
clear because the candidates don't own
up to these divisions but you could say
in the media said well there's
conservative less conservative and
moderate so that gives you four
positions libertarian conservative less
conservative and moderate and when you
look at the race only one slot really
has competition the libertarian
competition was over pretty early it was
Ron Paul Burress Gary Johnson remember
him and that slot was decided almost
before it began the kwasi moderate if
you want to call him at least for a day
or two was the Ambassador Huntsman he
has this slot all to himself if he wants
it though he spent much of the time at
least since the couple days around his
announcement trying to abandon his own
category and join some other one no one
has quite adopted him and Romney maybe
doesn't want it but he has the less
conserved
conservative slot all to himself or soon
will if the defeats Huntsman in New
Hampshire so the only slot where there's
a race within a race is the conservative
slaughter it's the only one with an
internal primary now some have wondered
whether this is really a slot or just
the anti Romney position well probably
it's a little bit of both but at least
when most people look at it they
perceive all the other candidates to
have been more conservative than Romney
be that as it may the candidates in this
slot have debated each other whether
often whether they are truly
conservative and it's attacked each
other for not being true conservatives
so there has been a kind of race going
on within the conservatives that has
involved ideology although as I
mentioned it seems to me the major
reason why people have fallen in this
category has not been so much their
defects of ideology but inadequacies in
their perceptions of personal competence
Newt Gingrich haven't fallen himself
he's not out of it yet certainly has a
new strategy some seem just being angry
he's compared himself I know to church
hill in washington but others now are
comparing him perhaps to achilles
brooding in his tent but anyhow he has
this new strategy of trying to combine
the remaining three conservatives into a
condominium and he's speaking of them
now as a group may Rick Perry and Rick
Santorum to somehow eliminate Romney
before these three turn on themselves as
triumvirate Saul ways do well no one's
quite sure how or whether this strategy
can work out or whether it's coherent
but it's one of the new things that's
come up in the last week well for a few
months now to go back to the pundits
I've tried to at least predict what the
race would be in terms of
Santa Gisele stick to the prediction
this goes all the way back to September
i think i gave Romney 70 chances in a
hundred the rest of the active field
that is all the other active candidates
three chances in 117 chances than a
hundred to someone who's not in the
field I don't know if I'd exactly stick
with that but that's pretty much where I
would be today what's the path to
victory for Romney well involves the
continuation of the internal primary
among the conservatives so that their
votes split for a while until it's too
late and you can imagine this continuing
to happen through South Carolina I kind
of split and then by that time maybe
it's too late for anyone to catch on
remember John McCain pretty much won the
election last time because the other
category split not because he was I
think held the best position and then
this is maybe more stronger point for
why Romney would win here in wins
against any conservative in the field on
the idea of his personality or persona
because here would be the reason because
he's need to be more presidential and
also add this because after you get past
the first number of these races it turns
out that when you look at the Republican
electorate while conservative group is
larger than the less conservative the
less conservative is a pretty big group
larger than one would think then when
you look just that Iowa so he would have
some ideological support but also I
think the element would turn on his
persona his competence and electability
well the centaurum path if he's the one
to victory you could see where that
could occur that really the largest
single element is the conservative one
if you can consolidate this and not
suffer from any of the major personal
flaws that all the other conservative
that has brought all the other
conservatives down well why not that
would be plausible and that's his hope
and time will tell let's go to the
broken convention a brokered convention
scenario
this was bandied about a little bit in
Washington with someone else getting
into the race I believe that never was
going to happen no one's going to get
into the race and start running in the
primaries now the way this would happen
would be quite different it would be
more like a modern draft the situation
would involve something like this for
this you need three candidates besides
Mitt Romney that is not just Ron Paul a
couple of others so that there's a split
of Delegates among the candidates Ron
Paul accepted he's going to get what
he's going to get because in any
two-person race even if you don't like
the two candidates someone wins its
definition to candidate someone wins so
you need I think three and it would
something be based on the fact that no
candidate gets a majority of the
delegates and that we and this I think
it's something we already know there's
not a passionate guts commitment to the
likely leader which would be Mitt Romney
and I think that's pretty clear about
his campaign you can see this from the
crowds if you've been to his rallies
there's not that sort of commitment that
either say Hillary Clinton or Barack
Obama had not that people don't like him
it just doesn't bring out that visceral
connection so i can't imagine people
fighting to the death for any of these
candidates so require as i said a split
among romney and two of the
conservatives they would have to hang on
because it was just between Romney and
one other conservative even either got a
majority Ron Paul would be able to
decide the difference so that would be
the basis of this people would conclude
gee we really don't have anyone who has
a majority or near majority without much
support enter some of the candidates
that many have wanted in that perfect
sweet spot that's a sweet spot that
someone a little bit more conservative
than Romney acceptable to all the
Conservatives acceptable as a mainline
candidate with the personal credentials
Jim a lot of people thought that was
going to be governor pawlenty and
I think he made a serious mistake and
pulling out he might have had a second
look and might have looked better but
there are others obviously in that slot
it could be Paul Ryan it could be Jeb
Bush who knows and I would imagine this
happening there for this minority
possibility in a kind of draft movement
emanating from some of the delegates who
had something whispered in their ear by
Washington insiders about how to do this
that would probably present the unity
ticket that as president and vice
president together a very attractive
ticket you can put together any pairs in
that group and you can imagine how
attractive that would be so that that in
my view is still remains more probable
outcome than any other candidate except
Mitt Romney who by far i think is has
the best position well
although this race may be decided in
terms of how many votes on matters
speaking out the final election race the
important ones it can be decided on many
matters like the vagaries of the
performance of the economy yet I think
beneath the decision of voters when you
look at its significance in a larger
context what all the thinking classes
have in mind you understand what an
important election it will be
Republicans have looked for a way to
phrase this and beginning in 2010 they
elevated the theme of exceptionalism as
the symbol which points the difference
between them and Democrats I think mark
Rubio made this the theme of his 2010
campaign he still believes in
exceptionalism Romney uses it in speech
and Newt Gingrich published the book on
this thing the very week issued the very
week in which he announced his candidacy
a long time ago and exceptionalism is a
wonderful phrase it evokes all sorts of
warm feelings among I think
conservatives the problem is that while
it's nice and poetic it doesn't get
through directly to what's at stake
because people say oh yes I like
exceptionalism but then they have
different understandings of what it
means it could be this could be that
America's strengthened Foreign Affairs
lots of Liberty it seems to break down
the moment you get beneath the word
itself so another way to think about how
many Americans conceive of this race
even if this won't be the dominant theme
inside the election in a popular that
for popular mark I'm about mobilization
is how Americans conceive of Europe
there is a this fact to keep in mind
just a few years ago say I'd say even
two years ago but certainly going back
to the time of the 2008 campaign up
until 2010 Europe was this symbol of
envy for the liberal intelligentsia you
could say they suffered from euro envy
they spoke about it all the time is the
model
bit more cautiously in public but still
go back and read the accounts of the
Intelligencia Europe was the model now
you hardly hear it whispered there are
grounds if we analyze this perhaps for
some hope for Republicans well what was
the image of Europe going into 2008 I
think we both parties agreed on this is
the image even though they evaluated it
differently here are the various
elements of what Europe was mentioned
three or four points in the minds of the
Intelligencia first year it meant a
large welfare state and a more managed
economy it was managed capitalism and as
you know Europeans continually attacked
the United States for its ultra
capitalism or capitalism on steroids
it's a cowboy capitalism meaning we
don't regulate the capitalism
sufficiently and of course a much larger
welfare state designed not only to get
benefits to others but to reduce
explicitly inequalities in society the
income spread in the United States is
always a matter of something that
Europeans have attacked of course it
means high-speed trains it's a cardinal
element of what Europe stands for and it
means the restrictions on labour markets
in protection of labour markets and
pensions so you could say it's a few to
put in more theoretical terms of you in
which the state or a society
collectively owns the well and
distributes it fairly as distinct from
the United States where at least that
the initial starting point was it used
to be the G everyone keeps what he makes
giving only what's necessary to keep the
government going that that would be a
little bit of the difference next these
are maybe lesser elements of the current
campaign but these are important
elements of what Europe meant in 2008
Europe was desirable for the Europeans
and
the American left because it presented
itself as a post national entity it had
gotten beyond or was in the process of
getting beyond the nation-state
spreading out pooling sovereignty the
nation-state was regarded in something
old and to such an extent let's not
forget this that Europe had the idea
which lists many people scratching their
head a little bit that Europe would soon
include Turkey and the states of the
Maghreb was proposed well why not if the
notion is somehow the nation's don't
matter which was the European idea this
would serve as a model not only for
Europe but for the world so in
combination with Europe and the
development of Europe was also the
development of more and more
international institutions like
international criminal courts and
international Accords as a new model to
bring peace inside the world which would
downplay the nation-state as really the
essential entity of organization of the
world says slow movement towards world
government really it was a kind of model
that Europe represented as I said in a
way that many thought very desirable and
then added to this is the European view
that G the this entity would be secular
and non foundational secular I mean it
wouldn't be attached even in by mission
to any religious preference you were
called the European Constitution was
this vague language that someone wanted
to put in that at least Europe was could
culturally been Christian now left out
is there going to be secular and non
foundational meaning you wouldn't
mention anything like natural rights or
anything that had some metaphysical
grounding to it rather what would hold
this idea hold the thing together would
be something like universal values
weather universal values being things
derived loosely from liberalism in a
certain way things like being humane
tolerant social justice so therefore the
quality aspect things like that but they
change a little bit as time goes on but
these would be the nice things that
would hold this together and eventually
the world together this I think was the
plan and finally the Europeans believe
and I think American liberals believe
that this was somehow the wave of the
future that it had the wind behind its
back or history behind its back and that
it was going to leave behind the
nation-state we behind those who cling
stubbornly to their patriotism and their
constitution that I think was what this
was the key about now this favorable as
I said liberals regarded this favorably
more or less conservatives agreed on the
elements of it but regarded it with
hostility I think the Liberals case at
least for liberals was strengthened as a
result of the momentarily as a result of
the crash in 2008 and in the narrative
that was presented after two days and
look it proves at least a good part of
the European case where did this crash
begin in the United States and where was
it thought to begin in the financial
markets of the United States
unrestrained unregulated it all came
from Wall Street in this view all which
proved and wavy at least to the
Europeans and to many of the liberals
the the European KSG that really is
something fundamentally wrong with the
American model and the European model
was the preferable one now we can speak
of the moment of turn this is this as
interesting as i said this grew into
2008 2009 what is it to begin that the
turn in the view of europe well whatever
the cause of this crash is one point it
became clear to many pretty early on
that europe seemed to have no way of
getting out of the economic doldrums its
economy which suffered more than ours
even though the crash began here its
economy didn't seem to have the dynamism
for growth and of course even in the
European model it was always admitted
that growth was less important in equity
they would trade some degree of grows
for equity but now in that in a period
of mounting unemployment which reached
much higher proportions in Europe than
here it was seeing that this was a
weakness in Europe where was the
capacity for getting ourselves out of
this whatever got us into it what would
get us out of it Europe didn't seem to
be the model but the more important
point is in one word which Greece here
we see the advent of another problem was
the problem or is the problem we face
really the financial crisis of 2008 or
is it something was much deeper that was
masked until now and no it's mixed up in
many people's mind with the financial
crisis one sees immediately it's
entirely independent of it that is that
the welfare states on many of the
welfare states have spent well beyond
their means they're in dedham tetanus is
gigantic so is the problem than the
financial crisis of 2008 or the crisis
of indebtedness this would be what what
what Greece has meant the symbol of this
crisis in the public mind namely that a
nation can go broke a nation that can
spend itself into bankruptcy a welfare
state can spend so much that it can no
longer maintain itself the symbol of
this has become Greece and it's one of
the most potent symbols of American
politics in this election year you can
go out to the hustings today and mention
Greece of all things and people have
some idea of what that means now it
means the government had spent itself so
much into debt that it goes bankrupt you
could maybe mention Illinois or
California but they're not there yet
we're working on it yeah and it's a
tangible sign because as I mentioned is
that people really don't vote on theory
at least many of the average voters
don't vote on theory they vote on
something that they can see and this is
the tangible importance of grace and now
this symbol of Greece dovetailed in the
United States was a movement that sought
to return to the founding and the
Constitution in the belief that the
founding of the Constitution somehow
holds the key to restraining
indebtedness well whatever the merits
this belief it turns out that the
authors of the federalist papers also
recurred to the example of Greece
classical Greece in their case to
illustrate a central problem of
republican government in america of
their day namely majority faction one
group voting away the rights of another
the two greek problems though different
on the surface in fact overlap in our
time the danger of faction assumes a
slightly different form it assumes the
form of a majority in one generation
dispossessing the rights of those in the
generation to come this generation our
generation let me say my generation
perhaps was diluted by unsound economic
theories and irresponsible politicians
it perhaps came to the belief that
someone or something other than
themselves would magically cover the gap
between what people want from government
and what they're willing to pay whatever
the source of the problems that facts
are there this generation is responsible
for it Thomas Jefferson surely had a
point in declaring that no generation
has a right just for its own benefit to
obligate those in generations to follow
he wrote suppose that a previous
generation has said to the moneylenders
give us money that we may eat drink and
be merry in our day with the next
generation he asked me if I'd be obliged
to pay the debt a good question where
we're thinking about well so I think now
what Greece means is that the real
problem is not that financial crisis are
unregulated capitalism that's not the
key element the key and central element
the element is debt and the debt crisis
and the consequences are symbolized in
what can happen to a nation completely
to lose in a sense its autonomy in its
power and it's not just the economic
factor of this but I think that moral
irresponsibility that has been bothering
people that is Jefferson suggests this
one what is the right involve the one
nation at one generation
decided to eat drink and be merry and
asking another generation to pay for
what is the moral right of this
something which is picked up today when
people say how can I ask my
grandchildren to pay for my debts and
suddenly from this point of view the
issues of income inequality if that's a
problem gee you might feel good by
speaking of social justice and humane
treatment and spreading the wealth
around now but what about the injustice
of leaving the next generation with the
bill isn't that a much greater injustice
than any conceivable injustice of the
income distribution here and now that I
think how many of come to see this
there's a the morally responsibility of
not taking ownership of this problem in
doing something about it but what about
the other elements of Europe these
aren't likely to play in the campaign
but it's given Republicans grounds to
think and certainly has led liberals to
speak less of Europe namely this idea of
Europe expanding to all peoples on the
basis of some humane idea of justice
look at what is happening in Europe
today who's speaking of the Justice of
the European community what they're
speaking of in the euro crisis is saving
the banks in France and saving the banks
in Germany from an economic collapse all
the highfalutin elements of a universal
model for world government have fallen
by the wayside it's as if they're
fighting many are fighting to save
Europe for saving Europe for no other
reason and then you ask about this idea
of a secular foundation lyst society
many in America look if they'd say well
what is Europe actually stand for today
what is it that enables it under these
circumstances it's fighting only to keep
a currency alive and can't give any
other reason it's led many to think that
gee maybe some firm foundation is the
way to go I think at least American
conservatives has
taking some heart and turning back to
American principles finding now that not
only this is something that they love
with the something that can compete in
the world as a model against this loose
and lukewarm general humanitarianism and
so conservatives ass is the wind on the
side of Europe now that I think is that
the great change just in the last year
or two well how is the left responded to
this collapse in the image of Europe and
in the collapse of its model it no
longer I said ever speaks of Europe is
the imager model it avoids the reality
altogether of what's happening there and
will try to run a campaign without ever
referencing the debt crisis it will keep
building Europe while never uttering the
name and this can be seen from President
Obama's Osawatomie speech which he gave
him Kansas a few weeks ago this is taken
to be kind of a statement of what the
campaign is going to be about he gave a
speech in Osawatomie maybe because
people can't pronounce it but them also
because that's where Theodore Roosevelt
gave one of his most famous speeches and
he came and went to compare himself to
to Roosevelt and to offer epoch-making
speech but if you read that speech the
debt issue is mentioned in one sentence
only what's referenced is more important
and as the key to what's going on is the
problem of income inequality of the one
percent versus the ninety-nine percent
and then the call for economic growth
but the economic growth houses to be
achieved through new government spending
in three areas education infrastructure
there's the high speed rail again and
cutting-edge industries like solar
energy and the new spending will be paid
for by will be paid for by taxation of
the rich but the old that has never even
mentioned I believe there are two
parties going into this election in Nova
the party of evasion and the party of
reality the party of reality may not
have all the solutions but the party of
evasion cannot have the answers it's
hard to see on what basis it could
successfully govern the country thank
yes I'm supposed to let our students I
think take microphones and then people
can hear this on webcast in Burma a
first question then dr. two things you
did not mention in your analysis of the
Republican side of the campaign your
opinion on the need for cash and for a
national organization both of which
we've seen as lacking in some of the
minor candidates yeah right I was basing
it really only one aspect but how the
voters make their decisions but sure
those elements are very important
Romney's has more but they also can be
overestimated somewhat I'd rather have a
appeal sustained appeal than cash or
organization though I prefer to have all
three and you'd see the problem of what
money can buy it Rick Perry's campaign
and I was very well funded and yet
hasn't been able to get off the ground
it's true that you could say that some
of the candidates coming on suffer from
this but I would look at the campaign in
2008 of McCain he was lucky to get
nominated but he had a very poor
organization during out the primaries
and at the point where before he got
going very little money so money follows
success and the problem is when you get
it quickly you don't know exactly how to
use it because you don't have the
organization and infrastructure but then
I imagine that if Rick Santorum does
well in New Hampshire he'll be flush
with cash enough to pursue the campaign
but you're right the absence of
organization has already hurt on these
candidates Santorum and Gingrich
included there's a number of states
where they actually had
been able to file slates for delegates
so if it comes down to you know the
margins that's where cash and
organization help at the margins and of
course anyone planning a campaign since
they don't know what's going to happen
the only thing you can plan in advance
that you know will remain stable is your
cash and your organization so everyone
puts everything into it even though it's
only important at the margins but
oftentimes elections are running the
margins still say though if one of these
candidates were really to catch whole
and something were to become unpalatable
about Mitt Romney someone with weak
organization and little cash could
easily make up those deficits yes we
have to have you bringing the microphone
on thank you for your excellent
presentation there is a major change in
voting rules in the Republican Party for
the president think the we have a
proportional representation through
april one analyst made a claim that if
the rules had been in effect in 2008
romney would have been the nominee
because mccain won a few winner-take-all
big states although we had probably only
a plurality what do you think of that
kind of analysis well good work for
political scientists one thing to keep
in mind because in something about the
rules is that you can go back and run an
election on different rules and get a
result except for one fact the
candidates would run their campaigns
differently under different rules now
that's not to say that there's not an
insight in your comment McCain was able
to win some winter take calls and parlay
that as it went along and get the
delegates but still people run elections
under the rules that exist and they put
their resources in strada
because of the rules that exist to the
extent that's important so that's point
to keep in mind it's this all came up in
the 2000 election could George Bush at
beaten Gore in the election if he had
known that it was going to be about
popular votes rather than electoral
votes if that was important well they
didn't do much to get out the vote in
Texas because it didn't matter he knew
he was going to win Texas so candidates
always run under the rules that exist
and that that's the slight problem I
have with that analysis that said what
really goes on in these races there's
the race for delegates and then there's
the race to show that you're the
candidate who commands the majority both
things are going on the delegate race
only makes a difference where it's close
and we saw that in 2008 between Hillary
and Obama but what good counts initially
is to show that you want to state and
that was true in two thousand dates 2012
most people aren't aware that the
delegates are in the Republican Party
for the first time are being awarded
proportionately they don't they don't
think of that they say gee he won a b c
and d and that can give an aspect of
inevitability and momentum so that's a
long answer the fact that sure it counts
but really what people are looking at
initially is who wins these states yeah
where our microphones can we bring them
around here oh good hello can you hear
me I can hear you fine just whether the
world I appreciate your insights this
morning you know a lot of people view
the political spectrum is left versus
right liberal versus conservative I'm of
the opinion that Liberty versus tyranny
and it's not unless voted an assault on
our freedom and a big part of our
freedom you touched on as the debt and
as long as we're on a fiat debt-based
money system which is what karl marx you
know advocated we're going to continue
in this
spiral down of debt do you see any
candidates offering commodity-based
currency as opposed to debt base
currency well ron paul is spoken of
moved a little bit in this direction and
um well i have the floor and something i
didn't i want to say something about ron
paul let me take a minute to say it here
because it's important it's true that
he's not going to get the nomination
because he represents a slot that has a
following the Republican Party but it's
not anywhere near majority nonetheless
this campaign is very interesting at
least for the future it shows something
of the appeal of libertarianism which is
grown and look where he got a lot of his
votes among young people and in college
campus towns and it is reflects
something that's been going on with the
philosophy of libertarianism being
discussed widely among younger people
today and having a certain following so
it's not surprising that the by far he
was the candidate who did best in those
areas of Iowa among the younger voters
but you can raise this and think a
little bit about libertarianism
obviously Ron Paul has helped at the
cause by pushing this for years and now
getting some recognition but you could
also ask whether he's hurt or limited
the cause and this question would go to
the faculty is the foreign policy
position that he had ticked articulates
intimately and theoretically connected
to the other parts of libertarianism or
could you have imagined a candidate with
a much more let's say traditional or
somewhat traditional view of foreign
policy with the libertarian domestic
views could you mention such a candidate
doing a heck of a lot better than Ron
Paul something to think about of course
you would have to go into the philosophy
of libertarianism and ask theoretically
whether there is some connection however
mild between the economic and the
foreign view and I think there is at
least some possible connection that
libertarians really heart we believe in
spontaneous order so if there's
spontaneous order and mark
why wouldn't it be spontaneous order in
international relations that's the
that's the connection but I know
libertarians who dispute that the other
thing is where Ron Paul's hurt the cause
which he's held is some of the people
that he was been associated with over
the years but you can begin to imagine
that the significance of that that
movement which I say won't win the
Republican nomination but it's
interesting back to your your question
where you might see the Republicans
mainstream Republicans going as the
Conservatives or less conservative is in
a concerted effort at beginning to
reduce debt and they express it in terms
less some express it in theoretical
terms like we should only have a state
that's as ABC and D that's part of it
but others express it in a more
pragmatic way they say look whatever our
debates are about a welfare state and
what the role and function of government
should be can't we begin to agree on a
number which would represent the maximum
amount of the percentage of gross
domestic product that the federal
government would spend bringing it back
to a range that we can afford and I
think that represents one view of the
number of the candidates bring the
spending down in four years from
twenty-four twenty-five percent to
twenty percent which in fact means a
heck of a lot of cutting and changing
and altering the welfare state without
arguing over the existence of the
welfare state itself as an idea is that
the welfare state should be about as big
as we can afford but no bigger and
that's the position for example that
Romney is suggested that he's going to
bring it to down to twenty percent
others have mentioned eighteen percent
it's pretty close to the paul ryan plan
you read paul ryan he doesn't say we're
going to eliminate the welfare state or
doesn't propose a view that government
we should have some absolute theory of
government which says exactly what
functions it should perform these are
implicit in some of the parts of the
plan but the real essence of the plan is
look whatever we're talking about its
got to be an arrange that we can afford
that should be the common good and
therefore this actually means cutting
back a lot of things some are
uncomfortable with romney on this base
bunson's that mentioned to hear and
speak a few times and he'll say there's
some things that maybe government would
be wouldn't be so bad if government were
doing if we could afford it but he said
we can't and the test i apply is it so
important that we should go we've been
willing to go to debt to China to secure
it it's a different standard than the
libertarian standard but it begins to
state of you that maybe Americans could
can live with yes this gentleman here we
have the microphone can you bring it
around here oh well you had mentioned
about the welfare state he had mentioned
about the welfare state and what mr.
Romney may do but as you well know mr.
dr. Paul has been a very strong advocate
of getting rid of the welfare state
because it's a major problem with the
illegal immigrants as well and but
question I'd like they ask is as far as
the different slots that you mentioned
what about the slot who is the one that
is the in the campaign that is the
greatest defender of the Constitution
well that wouldn't be a was it an
ideological slot they all speak about
the Constitution and how they love it
who would be the greatest defender hard
to say different people have different
views is the Constitution on some of
these issues I don't really don't have
an answer to who would be the greatest
defender of the Constitution it is a
heartening though this is one out one
result of the Tea Party that this
document called the Constitution which
more or less was abandoned as a matter
very much a public discussion suddenly
came back into the realm of public
discussion beginning really with the Tea
Party to the extent for example that
Congress actually opened the house
opened with the reading of the
Constitution much to Nancy
these initial dismay she came around and
she she she she read the clause which
spoke of how you choose the Speaker of
the House doing so this is important
because this question is what is the
Constitution is it merely a document
that's manipulated or used by a leads
namely lawyers in court cases is that
the core of what a constitution is or is
it somehow a living document that's
partly in possession of the public and
the people and that would guide our view
of government and I think you can give
credit to a number of candidates for
that Rick Perry it his own way wrote a
book on this or wrote a book with
someone else on this but up speaks a lot
about the Constitution and others of the
candidates have made it they at least
bent on a need to the Constitution so
it's heartening to see this document
returned from being merely a lawyer's
document to a document that can guide in
a way the broad contours of policy in
the United States and I think that's
what we really need to get back to and
thinking about the Constitution yes this
case before the Supreme Court about
Obamacare is interesting and important
than the rules of the Constitution
should be followed in their technical
legality but just as important as the
constitutional issue is should you have
something like Obamacare anyhow is this
a function the federal government that's
not something that's going to be decided
in the courts yeah so this would be an
issue you get back to answering the
question asking the question well what's
enumerated in which direction should
would be going in in a way there's two
kinds of constitutional discussions
therefore there's a legal technical one
which is important but I think not as
important as the broad ideas the
Constitution sets directions for the
country that it's incumbent upon the
parties and the political leaders to
support we get back in the back there
Charmaine well I couldn't resist the
opportunity to ask my professor a
question I'm glad I don't have to write
a paper at the end of it but I I have
been thinking a lot about your class in
the presidency
as a result of this particular slate of
candidates that we're faced with in
particular the oops moment thinking
about the theme of charisma that you
have written about and talked a lot
about in your work what I'm kind of a
mixed emotions and mixed mind on in
terms of the modern presidency and and
how that particular moment and others
similar to it have torpedoed Rick Perry
I mean he makes the argument that well I
shouldn't be totally judged based on my
performance and debates and in this
particular campaign it has had a larger
role than others but just to throw one
more thought into this mix is the whole
question of Mitt Romney and leadership
versus management so my overarching
question with this charisma management
leadership how do you see the academic
literature on the presidency and and
who's qualified and best qualified
coming to bear and just to show us some
light on this particular range of
candidates well I'm not sure that the
academic literature would be of much
guidance on this issue to be frank with
you but think of the moment this
question of the Perrys difficulties in
the debates I think that's one question
hurt him but that wasn't the only one I
don't think he was generally very strong
in the debates but you could you could
say given the system we have now not
imagining some other system some people
say well the debates counted too much
and as you know in this election cycle
this race the debates kind of more than
any other election cycle and pass
they've been really important a lot of
people have worried about that is
debating the skill that should be
important but if you're going to keep
the current system you would have to say
okay maybe debating isn't the most
important skill but what are the other
things that would take its place under
the circumstances that we have now and
what took to place maybe better mother
than worse is campaigning campaigning
and advertising underpass circumstances
debates would count a little bit less
what would count more is your daily
campaigning and your television
advertising that's been the trade-off
it's not moving from the debates to some
ideal view of judgment of virtues and of
course people say well campaigning isn't
that great either especially in the
modern mode it's given to demo goji and
look at television commercials their
scandal as many say so i guess i'm not
quite as down on the debates as others
they're all imperfect measures of what
makes the good leader but that I agree
but our system doesn't have a perfect
way to measure the good qualities of
leaders that no system is perfect in
that regard anyhow now your other s true
about charisma and management yeah I
mean this is the difference between 2008
and 2012 the Grayson 2008 was dominated
by a charismatic candidate you could say
charismatic disease and here we
shouldn't really blame Obama as much as
11 likes what's really should blame is
the need that people express to have a
person like this I mean what's the real
disease Obama merely took advantage of
it he was the person who took advantage
of it and mind you this was not an
American movement this was a worldwide
movement Obama was heralded and still is
heralded but was heralded throughout the
entire world heck he wasn't running for
president of the United States he was
right in for president of the world and
almost literally and conceived himself
now maybe his problem was that people
him and the people around actually began
to believe this that was the danger but
he did it at least built fulfill
something I'm not sure that the people
in 2012 want that quite as much whether
that's quite as important to the
American people this time around they
may have had their their moment of
charisma of scratching their heads and I
think you're pointing to Romney he's
sure he doesn't inspire that way
he's maybe more than a manager but he
touts his managerial ability and so he's
going to have to say this is the fit for
the moment or it's the best you can get
one of the two I think you can make an
argument that it's a good fit for the
moment that we don't want the charisma
but in any case it's going to boil down
to two people whatever their strengths
their weaknesses and if you look over
the candidates in the past they've all
fallen short in a lot of ways they've
never been the perfect candidate and
will boil down to 22 individuals whoever
they are and have to make a judgment
with some lacking qualities you might
otherwise wish them to have yes okay
well then you assign it David end thank
you
well the things you mentioned that just
keep this in mind in any movement and
the Tea Party was a movement you have to
balance out the good in the bad and sure
you can make the fine distinctions and
the Republicans could have controlled
the Senate with the two better let's say
nominations but look at the sorts of
persons in the Tea Party they've been
brought into the government and given
renewed energy to the Republican Party
so no one ever can find tuna movement
that's the character of a movement it's
big it's flat footed it pushes sometimes
it pushes too far and that's what I
think happened in Nevada and in Delaware
just it was a cup of tea too far good
hard work that way but look at the
others like Rubio I mean others boy that
people were initially single let's boots
back Chris I mean look look at the
difference between those and a lot of
the tea party orgy party insolence
candidates are terrific and have served
the Republican Party well so the part of
the answer is you're never going to be
able to to calibrate it perfectly or do
the perfect slot things to avoid well
it's pretty obvious I I would say that
you want to stick to these to the
central issues of the top of the day and
i believe the situation's really do
revolve around the the debt the
sustainability of liberal democracy and
the moral issues connected with the debt
and that the other issues would take
however important would be second to
that that dominant theme thank